thanks uh sriram
uh so
so promote ended with uh with mentioning
who he worked with i should start with
uh mentioning who i worked with in
particular this is basically an
abbreviated version of the thesis
defense talk of my student
shang tsai
mayak bakshi who just started as faculty
research faculty in hong kong and my
colleague mingwa all at the chinese
university uh i'll be talking about a
framework so i'll be talking about a
bunch of different past recovery
problems but but really maybe the
take-home message is
that there's a bunch of similar ideas
that work in a variety of such problems
i'll try to highlight what they are
actually many of these are very similar
to stuff that kanan and his group have
been doing at berkeley uh you know it
started sort of started happening in
parallel and then a little bit of a
friendly competition right in terms of
who comes up with algorithms or
different things first but the design
philosophy that both of us and in fact
others also use is similar so try to
highlight that
um all right and as always thanks to to
cohk for supporting me and in particular
the institute of network coding and in
particular my group those of you who
were here on monday this is codes
algorithms networks design and
optimization for information theory at
this point i would normally take this
off and there'll be the t-shirt group
t-shirt below
except it's dirty so i can't really
verify it
yeah
all right so sparse recovery now
in the literature sometimes past
recovery has come to mean just
compressor sensing and certainly that's
one type of sparse recovery problem and
i'll talk about it but but i'll try to
convince you that similar approaches
could work in a variety of different
estimation problems where you want to
under where you want to estimate a
signal that is sparse it's it's in a
huge dimensional space but the ambient
the ambient dimension is huge but the
actual somehow signal content is
concentrated in some sparse subset
uh and you have some measurement process
it could be linear or non-linear and
i'll describe what each of these four
different
measurement processes and problems are
uh you know so compressor sensing one
way of motivating it is one of many
different ways of motivating it is you
have a base station a bunch of different
cell phones are talking to it they're
getting some noisy versions of it the
base station can really only hear things
that are close to it so so how does it
try to reconstruct what people are
saying right and
and the way of thinking about this is of
all possible cell phones that are
potentially speaking different things uh
the the base station is going to get
some linear combination of those things
of all possible n cell phones only k are
sort of close enough for it for
for the base station to hear them and
from this measurement process uh like of
the n people who are potentially
speaking in in just m time slots you
want to reconstruct what each of them
was saying uh the you know the since
different different cell phones are
different distances away and some of
them could be speaking at the same point
in time so you could get linear
superpositions so in general there's
some linear combination of uh which was
in the previous slide there's some
linear combination of what people are
saying uh which represents what what
you're getting right and from these
linear combinations you want to
reconstruct x so if you know the if you
know the sort of channel transitions if
you know what the relationship is
between the inputs and the outputs you
want to reconstruct the the vector
um
in
in particular this this makes sense if
you have far fewer time slots than than
the number of cell phones right you want
to reconstruct that uh but it of course
it has to be at least as many as the
number of cell phones you want to
reconstruct right this is this is one
motivation and in particular sometimes
you have uh you have noise and you have
approximate sparsity so sometimes
you want to reconstruct your your x
vector
even though there's some noise in the
measurements there's some e added to it
near the end uh or
and there's approximate sparsity so the
cell phones which are far away are also
giving a little bit of interference
right so so that's that's maybe a more
general sparse recovery setting and in
particular i'll in the in in the next
few models i'll even relax the
requirement that a has to be linear
sometimes your measuring process is
inherently non-linear i'll describe a
couple of such measurement processes as
well okay but the the goal is going to
be similar
x is lying in a high dimensional ambient
space but its actual signal content is
concentrated within some k
some k which is much less than n number
of indices number of coordinates you
want to reconstruct x knowing a which is
some linear nonlinear measurement
process and knowing why
in the presence of potential
with approximate parts dm noise okay
to simplify things i'll be talking about
in this talk i'll ignore the effects of
of noise and approximate sparsity but
these can be handled by some somewhat
standard techniques all right so just
just to get a sense of things what's the
network thermography problem so there's
a network um you know what the topology
is like but you know there are some
bottleneck links you want to estimate
which links are bottleneck links what
you get to measure are end-to-end
measurements you get to measure you put
in a packet at one side of the network
you get to measure the end-to-end path
delays and from these end-to-end
measurements you want to figure out well
what are the link-wise path delays
hopefully very few of them are
are actually
delayed
so so these are sort of linear
measurements but the restricted linear
measurements you can only take
measurements based on the network
topology right and this introduces its
own set of challenges
uh here's a third model compresses phase
phase retrieval so here you have
non-linear measurements so here uh maybe
you're getting the intensity
measurements of something which is uh so
you have some underlying real signal so
maybe that corresponds to someone's face
and you know the you also want to figure
out the distance of each pixel on the
face from the camera from the camera
lens uh so so somehow there's the
intensity that corresponds to the
amplitude of the of the light coming
from you but it's also the phase the
phase corresponds to how far away the
that particular pixel on the faces from
the lens right so so i like the joke
this is like
phase recov face recovery from phase
recovery uh that's that's one way you're
thinking about it uh and and here you
just get to measure the intensities so
that's and i'll talk a little bit more
about algorithms for that
finally there's uh the group testing
problem again it's a non-linear problem
and again many of you probably already
know what it is i'll just do a quick uh
overview so there's a bunch of people
some of them have a disease you want to
figure out who has the disease and there
are n people k of them have a disease
and but instead of testing them
individually you test pools of them you
test groups of them
these tests are disjunctive measurements
these are like all measurements so you
mix the blood from different people
together and the goal is to try to
figure out who has the disease with the
minimum number of tests right
and again you could have noise sometimes
various things could happen but notice
these tests are non-linear right because
if even one person in the pool you're
testing has the disease then then you'll
get a positive test outcome otherwise
you'll get a negative test outcome so
here you have again inherently nonlinear
measurements you want to reconstruct the
signal from these things
all right so four different models but
my claim is that somehow similar
underlying ideas work
so so my goal is going to be just to
explain the intuition for the linear
model
without too many details and then show
how for one of the non-linear models for
phase recovery how you know you have to
tweak so so the same idea doesn't work
exactly in each of the models you have
to tweak but how do you tweak and i'll
give you one of those examples okay
all right so
uh so let's start with this compressor
sensing and uh here's here's the uh this
this particular the idea for the slide
we stole from uh from sameer power
slides uh uh kanan students uh a really
nice way of explaining things so um
the the idea as well let's say there's
five
guardians who are trying to guard some
gold bars one of them is actually well
he's actually instead of being a
guardian he's stealing some gold from
his gold bars so he steals an unknown
amount of gold from from each bar under
his control and you know you want to
figure out who it is which one is it how
much is he stealing so so with the
minimum number of weighings so
you know each of them should be 100
grams so because you can be them you can
figure out there should be 100 grams so
one way of doing this is to is to
measure uh like the total amount of um
is to total just to measure the total
amount of uh
weight if you take one from each uh from
each stack you figure out it's 490 so
that tells you okay what what he's
stealing should be roughly 10 grams
right and that's like taking a linear
measurement of this form you're just
sampling you're just taking the
summation of x i's with coefficients
which are one and you figure out that
it's like minus 10
and then i'm sure many of you have seen
something like this before then you take
a unequal number you take you know
different numbers of gold bars from each
stack and then you get some linear
measurement which you know which looks
kind of like this you figure out it's so
the in this measurement x minus 40 so it
must have been the case that the
that the fourth stack was actually the
bad uh the bad guy right because the
ratio of the total weight in the second
measurement to the first measurement was
four so it must be in this guy okay
so notice even though like in principle
this this measurement is measuring a
large number of people it's measuring n
people like a single measurement is
enables you to figure out which guy it
must have been it's like this bad guy
has left a signature uh which with a
with a small number of measurements with
two measurements the first measurement
to figure out what the difference must
have been and the second measurement to
sort of normalize it you can figure out
which guide must be right
and this is in some sense the the take
the take away message of uh of this
thing so so this this quick
reconstruction can happen because our
measurements are somehow structured so
if there's some structure to the
measurements
and here i've given an example with a
very carefully chosen structure right
just to make it obvious but but if
there's some structure to the
measurements often
not only do you get information
theoretically optimal recovery but you
also get very fast information
theoretically optimal
time complexity also in recovery
and let me let me repeat that
in i think an upcoming slide well a
couple of slides down the line so
um
well okay i'll repeat it later one more
idea so second version of the gold bar
puzzle supposes two different uh thieves
what do you do so suppose by by magic
suppose you know that this is a bad
group so what's a bad group a bad group
is one which has too many thieves yeah
you don't really have any hope of
figuring something out
and suppose by magic you know that
something is a good group it has at most
one thief in it so then you can you can
somehow
iteratively use the same process you can
uh so you can you can try looking at the
bad group uh you can look at these
structured measurements the ratio will
give you something that's not an integer
so so this tells you okay this group is
bad it has too many bad guys so maybe
let's not start with this group let's
instead start with a good group
so this group happens to give you a
ratio which happens to be an integer so
maybe it's a good group maybe it has
just one bad guy in it uh so so now that
you've figured out that this is a bad
guy so so now you figure out who the bad
guy it is you then do some cancellation
because after all these measurements are
linear right and then and then the the
ratios in the in the previous group
which is a bad group now becomes a good
group and then you can figure out who
the bad guy is in the in the previously
bad now good group right so so this
process is should be familiar to many of
you this is basically just appealing
process um
and you know this shows up all the time
in coding theory so so the second idea
is just just sort of linear
cancellations and in the linear setting
two of the problems i mentioned are
linear this this works out you can do
linear cancellations it gets trickier in
the non-linear setting you have to
that's where usually most of the
tweaking needs to be done you need to
figure out how to mimic such a linear
process even though you have nonlinear
measurements and you know something else
is needed over there okay
all right so
uh
so so that's basically
that's one of the major themes of this
talk you can you can represent each of
these things by
by some bipartite graph
and if you have a singleton that's like
the good group again we've stolen
notation gleefully from from kanan's
group
so if you have a singleton measurement a
singleton measurement corresponds to a
group that you're measuring
which happens to have just one good guy
then then using this using that gold bar
puzzle idea you can figure out who who
who the bad guy in this group must have
been who the non-zero component that's
in this case that's x3 must have been in
this measurement and then once you
figure that out then you can do some
cancellation you can figure out uh you
can cancel the effect of that thing out
uh you know pass the message back to the
other side and then what was originally
a multi-ten what is originally a bad guy
what is originally a measurement which
had more than one non-zeros can be
cancelled out it becomes a singleton uh
and then you can you can decode
so so basically this comes down to
trying to prove two things so you want
to prove that there are good bipartite
graphs that are these good measurement
processes uh where
you know you have these output
measurements on the right hand side the
inputs on the left hand side you have
these good measurement processes where
at least a significant fraction of the
measurements are singletons to begin
with because the singleton somehow allow
you to bootstrap the process you start
off with a green node you start off with
a with a node which has got just one bad
guy in it one non-zero component in it
then you you figure out what the
component must have been the value then
you cancel and so on right so so first
of all you need to guarantee that there
are some such good graphs this again is
somewhat standard from from techniques
in uh in you know encoding theory codes
over graphs so one type of analysis
tends to be along the lines of
i'm jumping ahead quite a lot
tends to be along the lines of
you know looking at expansion properties
of graphs or other techniques which
which i guess i'll mention briefly later
but really again the key message that i
maybe want to get across which is
slightly less uh
less appreciated though again some
people uh including the two have looked
at it that uh instead of just choosing
bipartite instead of just stopping at
the point at which you choose the
bipartite graphs if you also figure out
like once you have the corresponding
bipartite graph what values to put over
there instead of just putting zeros and
ones if you put values along on the
nonzero components carefully that those
choices of values you put over there
also have a role to play they don't
necessarily have a role to play in terms
of minimizing the number of measurements
quite as much as they do in terms of
minimizing the amount of time required
to reconstruct so so the if you care
about computational complexity as well
as sample complexity then then choosing
these these measurement matrices
somewhat carefully uh helps and and
actually one can also argue that in some
settings
these measurement ensembles actually
happen naturally the the cell phone
example i gave i i claim uh
and i can i can talk more about it if
you're interested but i claim that that
cell phone example for example naturally
fits in the in the ensemble of matrices
that you'd like over here okay
this is all very sort of hand wavy
philosophical i hope to give just a
couple of concrete examples i have
around 10 minutes so i'll maybe look at
the phase retrieval part
so a contribution again is
is not just minimizing the number of
measurements but also in minimizing the
decoding complexity
and uh and
as an example of the type of algorithm
that you can guarantee here so so it's
sort of clear that if you have a case
bar signal out of you know something
that's that's sitting in ambient
dimension n you can't hope for less than
k measurements less than or order k time
because after all just writing out
the input itself will take order k time
right and there's a bunch of previous
work which is you know it tries to
optimize the decoding complexity or the
measurement complexity but but if you if
you do this you can you can basically
hit both almost bang on up to small
constant factors like constant factors
which you can explicitly calculate which
are of the order of two or thereabouts
for the number of measurements or up to
15 or so for the
in terms of the the decoding complexity
so literally really quite spectacular
yeah
all right so so that's what happened
again just to highlight uh this parallel
work by kanan's group which is which is
really quite nice they did optimize the
measurement so we had order optimal
results
they actually optimize the constraints
and have some really nice results
um
okay so that's for compressor sensing
and you know in the interest of time
i think people have already gotten a
flavor of what's happening so you know
there's some expansion properties which
allow you to prove the goodness
existence of good graphs i'm going to
skip over that i'm going to skip over
the
what that what that peeling process
really is like you know we choose to do
it by a complex matrices you can there
are other ways of doing it there are
reasons to use complex matrices i'm
going to skip over all of that
just to give uh just to give a sense of
something i'll try to talk about the
compressive phase retrieval this is uh
this is the non-linear part right so
um
so so again you have a signal it's
sparse so your x is has just k out of n
non zero components you want to figure
out what it is but what you get are not
quite linear measurements you get
intensity measurement so you get the
absolute value of the summations of
of aixi something like this right and
again think of this as the the just that
just your your photon detector can only
count the number of photons coming in it
can't count it can't figure out the
phase maybe okay so
so from these from these amplitude
measurements you want to figure out the
original signal
and
part of the challenge is well if you
think about it
you can't really hope to reconstruct the
signal exactly like for example suppose
you're you're out so suppose you're
the before you took the intensity before
you took the amplitude your a times x
the linear measurement of a times x had
was something like 2 times e to the iota
pi by 3 then you know once you look at
the intensity then you'll get a 2 at the
output right but even if this was
you know even if this was multiplied by
2 to the iota theta by 2 even if you
multiplied the whole thing by you you
rotate to the phase of the whole signal
by e to the iota theta you would still
get two at the output over there right
so
so at least up to a global phase you
can't hope to reconstruct the signal but
uh so again if you have some signal you
could rotate the whole signal by e to
the iota theta you would still get the
same output so up to a global phase you
can't hope to do any you can't hope to
do better than that but indeed it turns
out you can reconstruct the signal up to
a single global phase after a single e
to the iota theta
it's non-trivial to figure out what's
the minimum number of measurements
required to do this
we don't try to get the information
therapy optimal number of measurements
but we get up to a small constant factor
of it okay
so
so in this case again it's a you can try
using a similar idea you can try
figuring out singleton so you can try to
take measurements so that you can figure
out the intensities of various things
right so so so you you have that
um
but then the problem is the cancellation
doesn't quite work because now you're
getting absolute values of of
intensities right so you can't quite
cancel things out so you have to be
careful here right and uh
the so peeling is not allowed because
you can't you just get absolute value of
x1 absolute by x2 but you know taking
the difference of these two is is hard
and you also want to figure out not just
the magnitude you want to figure out the
phases
so so here's a simple little idea uh
which
which which is basically so suppose
someone gives you
the the magnitude of x1 magnitude of x2
and magnitude or x1 plus x2 for example
or some linear combination of them then
then you know by
thank you then by the triangle
inequality you can sorry by basic
trigonometry you can figure out must
have been like this or or actually you
know the sum degeneracy it could have
been the flipped version so if you if
you know the if you know the magnitudes
of two different numbers and some linear
combination of them you almost know what
the what the angles between them must be
so if you just take one more measurement
let's say you know x1 plus iota x2 and
so on then you can figure it out exactly
you can figure out it must have been uh
the the one on the left hand side okay
in this case so so basically the idea
here is well with some extra number of
measurements you can you can take care
of this degeneracy you can try to figure
things out so what does this mean it
means that if you have measurements
which which have something like the
sigma structure over here so what's the
sigma structure so let's say you have a
measurement you have a singleton you
have a measurement where the the
corresponding non-zero node being
measured is only x one like it could
have other nodes being measured but all
of those have zero magnitude so only one
nonzero node is being measured in this
y1 only one nonzero node is being made
in y2 and there's a there's a double tin
there's a node in the middle which is
measuring both of these nonzero nodes so
in this scenario in this sigma structure
sort of way you can hope to reconstruct
both of the x ones and the x twos right
because this will give you the magnitude
of x one this will give you the
magnitude of x two and this could give
you some linear combinations of the
magnitudes of x one and x two right
so so the trick then comes down to
figuring out well what sort of graphical
structures have a decent number of sigma
structures right and and that's really
where we're very
like what you have to analyze so so over
here like um
so some of these slides are because of
my student and you know
my group we like our bigly animations
and i've lost track of which things we
gonna oh oh that's right so so this
thing is biggling right this is a sigma
structure okay there we go so
uh so this is a sigma structure you can
you can decode using this one um and and
and now you have something like a multi
10 so in this case
this y3 is a linear combination of x2 x4
x6 all of which are nonzero so right now
this is not necessarily that useful to
help us decode right so so at this point
we could we could really call it a
useless node so certain like a basic you
know just just
you can calculate the expectation that
you'll have
singletons you'll have double turns you
can calculate expectations of of sigma
structures and so on and things work out
in expectation um and
and all of that works out
the you need some nifty algebra to make
sure that you can do cancellations
carefully it turns out if you very
carefully choose your measurements then
uh
then you can then you can solve
quadratic equations and try to figure
out uh what what the what the
corresponding nonzero components must be
like i'm getting close to my time so you
know i'm rushing through things let me
just say much of this is algebra like
the basic message i want to get across
is
the the linear peeling process is hard
to do but you can replicate that by by
carefully choosing your measurements
again the message to take away here is
you want to choose your measurement
ensemble so that so that given the
specific nonlinearity of the problem you
can try to undo that non-linearity and
be able to to peel and so on uh so so
with a bunch of different tricks and
suitably choosing your ensemble it turns
out that you can uh
you you can then patch together so once
you know the relative phase between x1
x2 between x2 and x3 and so on then you
can figure out as long as you have a
connected graph as long as you have
enough of these sigma structures you can
figure out what the relative phases of
each of the non-zero components must be
with respect to each other
and and by carefully optimizing the
degree distribution and so on you can
figure out you can get it down to order
k measurements order k log k decoding
complexity again uh
uh this happened to be also a problem
that uh conan's group and his students
also looked at and there's there's some
nice work there i'm not going to go over
the degree distribution optimization uh
let's not worry about it uh one minute
and i'm basically giving my final sort
of take home message which is um
so so even here you can get order k
complexity well order k
number of measurements nearly order k
complexity not quite that and even for
the for the group testing problem
depending on which version you're
looking at it's close to order k you
know the information theoretically
optimal number of measurements and
decoding complexity i'm not going to go
into the details but the take-home
messages
you want a good bipartite graph these
these things have been examined fairly
well in the coding theory literature but
when you choose the structure you choose
the non-zero components you decide what
to put in them and somewhat carefully
then in that case uh in that case your
your decoding complexity can can
drastically be sped up right and
yeah these singletons multitudes help a
lot
i'm done
thank you very much sid we'll take a
question while
so
but because it's non-linear so
so if if for these phase recovery
problems you have to do these
cancellations then you have to do it
carefully uh for phase recovery it turns
out you can do it
depending on the type of non-neurality
for group testing more challenging so
you know
problem dependent
thank you